welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness's latest trailer
just delivered some of the biggest
marvel fan payoff ever by confirming
patrick stewart charles xavier leader of
the x-men as part of the mcu now but
there is an even crazier cameo in this
trailer if you listen closely to the
illuminati shaming doctor strange in
that moment we should tell him the truth
i don't ever want to see it again
ever yes between a mystery glowing
figure trading blows with wanda and
ultron centuries as the foot soldiers of
this illuminati citadel speculation has
exploded that a variant of tony stark
the superior iron man could appear in
multiverse of madness maybe even played
by long-time band bandcasted tom cruise
who alongside robert downey jr back in
the mid-2000s was originally considered
for the role of iron man giving us a
glimpse into that alternate reality but
i'm going to explain who exactly this
alternate version of tony stark is the
multiversal logic that makes his
membership on the illuminati perfect for
the mcu and what role he could play in
multiverse of madness and beyond so in
the latest trailer doctor strange is
detained in a facility that's actually
shot in london's british museum home of
the rosetta stone an artifact really
used as the next point among
anthropologists to help them bridge
together various ancient languages which
may be why charles xavier as a student
of history chose this whole look as his
nexus bridge across realities but doctor
strange is escorted by ultron sentries
these are the drones built by ultron in
age of ultron but originally part of
tony stark's iron legion protocol to
build a suit of armor around the world
until the mine stone ai corrupted the
algorithm and turned it edil but the
fact that these are now the foot
soldiers tell us that someone in this
compound is using this exact generation
of stark tech but as stark initially
intended it to work then strange faces a
six-chair deus helmed by patrick stewart
charles xavier with the other five
authorities for now at least left a
mystery but this is almost certainly
marvel's six-member illuminati which in
the comics was founded by tony stark now
throughout this trailer wanda breaks
into and attacks this compound facing at
least one glowing figure now in most of
these shots the person looks like monica
rambo or her mother maria rambo going
binary the way captain marvel does but
maybe monica tapping into her photon
abilities that she gained in
wondervision now i will admit some
angles look a bit more armored up and if
you pause at one particular frame the
motion blur does make the figure look
like the hair is different and the
lighting around the mouth a bit more
goatee like it's just hard to tell with
this quality one still frame being
shared around twitter from vfx still
being rendered doesn't really do it
justice ultimately i just doubt marvel
would introduce a variant tony stark
like this after being so strategic and
so deliberate with how they teased
patrick stewart but i totally get why
fans think iron man will show up in this
movie and i totally agree with him i
think he will because based on the
ultron sentries alone and this being a
multiversal illuminati this has to be
pointing at superior iron man and
multiverse madness in the marvel comics
superior iron man emerged from what was
called the axis event in which magic
reversed the morality of earth's heroes
and villains but the corrupted tony
stark shielded himself from that spell
being reversed and so he stayed evil
becoming what was known as the superior
iron man he got society addicted to the
extremist 3.0 virus via an addictive app
he used an army of drones as a police
force until the jackass was eventually
killed off in an incursion when the
marvel universe in the ultimates
universe collided which was part of the
stepping stones leading up to the 2015
secret wars event all of this lines up
perfectly with what marvel studios now
seems to be setting up with an ultron
century guarded multiverse overseeing
illuminati as this entire cinematic
universe braces for future crossover
events like avengers secret wars now our
friends at upstart want you to start
this year off right by getting out from
under the credit card debt it'll both
help your peace of mind and you don't
even have to buy smaller pants like
those with other popular resolutions
upstart can help you make that final
payment so you can break the cycle of
debt and get ahead upstart is a fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get one fixed monthly
payment upstart knows that you are more
than just your credit score and is
expanding access to affordable credit
rather than looking at credit score
alone upstart considers other factors
like your income your current employment
and credit history to find you a smarter
rate for your loan you can check your
rate without impacting your credit score
in minutes for loans between one
thousand to fifty thousand dollars
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com new rockstars that's
upstart.com new rockstars use our url to
let them know that we sent you
upstart.com new rockstars by simply
including these ultron sentries this
confirms that this compound runs on star
tech but coming from a universe where
ultron drones can be trusted and
controlled while one could argue that
they're being controlled by an evil
ultron himself i just don't think ultron
or ultron infinity would really want to
join any multiversal council rather this
looks like a successfully realized
version of tony stark's original
intention for ultron to be a fully
automated ai designed to operate his
iron legion and keep the peace peace in
our time however let's game that out if
there were a reality in which ultron
never betrayed tony stark tony never
would have learned those critical
lessons of responsibility that age of
ultron taught him he never would have
moved avengers tower out of manhattan to
the more remote compound in upstate new
york there would have been no sokovia
disaster to guilt-trip him with in civil
war he just really would have spent a
lot more time drinking showing off
trying to lift mjolnir and making poorly
aged primonocta jokes yeah thanks for
that one joss to be honest he just would
have aged into a smug prick outsourcing
all of his avengerine to a fleet of
drones and someone who super importantly
for this film never ever got to know the
sokovian twins whose parents were killed
by one of his bombs wanda maximoff would
have been just some random hydra
controlled witch who gave him a
terrifying nightmare and then bounced
and we know how important that nightmare
was to the tony stark of the mcu but in
this case it leaves us with a
live-action version of the superior iron
man a jerk who loves to have his toys do
everything for him but a guy always
fearing the one witch who got away now
juan in this trailer said that vision
theorized about the multiverse proving
that tony stark's jarvis ai tech
eventually would have explored
multiverse theory on its own and perhaps
given this tony stark variant access to
navigate the multiverse without having
to use linear quantum time travel like
our robert downey jr tony stark did now
again i think the fact that we have a
multiversal illuminati tells us that
this multiverse is really worried about
incursions and it's all leading to what
i believe will be the fifth avengers
film secret wars and in the 2015 comics
of that doctor doom brings back all the
marvel heroes and villains in a big
multiversal arena called battle world
it's awesome however i would be
surprised if superior iron man even made
it that far because if he is played by a
cameo as nuts as tom cruise this sounds
like a bit of stunt casting in which tom
cruise plays an insane scene-stealing
role where he goes hard like he did for
his cameo and tropic thunder for cruz
this would just be the meta opportunity
to show what he could have done after he
was considered for the role in the
mid-2000s before robert downey jr was
cast and just really had fun with it
lots of fun until the ghost of his past
bloody wanda kicks down the door and
wipes the floor with him i would just
hope that before that happens this movie
could show us a quick what if style
montage of this iron man's past history
but those iconic mcu moments tom cruise
swapped in for robert downey jr like
hammering the armor in the cave with a
box of scraps pulling off his shades
during the press conference saying i am
iron man teaming up with war machine and
iron man 2. except now it's back to
being terrence howard all the way to his
fateful line to thanos and in game hell
disney and lucasfilm already hired vfx
artist shamook to fix luke skywalker and
this guy made a great rendering of tom
cruise as iron man i mean who knows that
might have been part of the reason why
this guy was hired so i just cannot wait
to see this superior iron man freak out
when wanda begins yanking out the hearts
of his precious ultrons
check out our great merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at evos following
your rockstar subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you
[Music]